[Music]
from the studio that made you mutual and
on facebook comes one of the most
insanely idiotic things that you will
ever see at no point in this rambling
incoherent film will it come even close
to anything that could be considered a
rational thought everyone in the theater
will be dumber for having seen it
so i awarded all the points and make god
make minions of us all
minions the rise of grue
now that pixar has coined the market on
depressing your kids the minions are
free to continue their loony reign of
terror
with returning favorites like stuart
he's stewart kevin he's up
next and the other one
that one has braces cute in this wacky
franchise where all the bad guys are the
heroes and all the heroes are their
adorable little slaves don't worry they
like it
[Applause]
see it's in their nature to work on paid
for life unions are the real super
villain right bob
remember the last minions movie neither
does this minions movie because they
forgot the minions already know grew and
that is how the minions found their new
boss when you guys responded to my
health wanted that forgot gru already
knows dr nefario if you ever get famous
remember who gave you your first gadget
forgot that 11 year olds tend to look
different eight years later and
you know what why don't we even bother
minion like banana then you fly plane go
boom
watch gru become the houseboy of an old
san francisco leather daddy in his harem
herb henchmen they're taking the fight
to the vicious six a diabolical gang of
70s movie tropes led by the most neck
rowing sassy character in animation
history and they literally had beyonce
play nala she's flanked by an ageless
jean-claude van damme it's time for the
next generation
sir you are 60 and a nun who proves that
yes catholicism exists in the minion
verse and he is on the side of evil
[Music]
together they'll steal the ancient
artifact that grant you the power to
steal the ending from kung fu panda but
let's be honest this is a better
sinister six movie than whatever sony is
cooking up
if you want to watch steve carell with a
big nose and a funny voice abuse some
underlings check out fox catcher
ungrateful ape
but if you want to take an animal and
zone out for 90 minutes then it's crew
time baby because this one is full of
slapstick comedy
fart jokes
[Music]
and silly nonsense gibberish like
spanish
[Music]
that's still way down by a constant
stream of boomer references too old for
even today's parents
[Music]
crafting comes alive nice choice easy
there don rickles who's done wrinkles
kids these days don't know about don
rickles he's the guy from toy story ages
3 and up i'm not supposed to be
babysitting princess drool
so drop your expectations lower than
this little dude's pants and try to just
kind of go limp mentally for a cartoon
that's not exactly breaking new ground
but it's guaranteed to entertain little
kids adults studying for their ged and
gen z years coping with the eminent end
of their childhoods welcome to the real
world kids where everyone is somebody's
minion
story
i'm gru
simpson's tumors raiders of the lost are
good cleopatra clones yo mama jokes bad
boy records john claude van damme okay
that's a good one xena warrior pryorus i
must scare you
machete grunts in a booth for an hour
and young sheldon
grassic world dominions
[Music]
it's not winning any oscars but this is
easily the second best michelle yo and a
googly-eyed rock movie of 2022
broadcast the boom boom boom boom and
make them all dance to it
elmo and homer simpson eat black
spaghetti cha-cha-cha
megatron you took my voice you will
never rob anything from anyone ever
again